للصين مصلحه استراتيجيه في انتصار بوتين
تريد تقديم الدعم لروسيا لكن في نفس الوقت
لا تريد المخاطره بالعقوبات الغربيه على
اقتصادها وهي التي لتوها فتحت حدودها منذ
سنوات من الاغلاق بسبب كورونا هذا ما
ناقشه بوتينغ خلال زياره الاخير لموسكو
بحسب تقرير لشبكه سي ان بي سي لكن لا شيء
ياتي بالمجال او حسب المثل الصيني لا عشاء
مجانيا ليكون السؤال ماذا ستستفيد الصين
من روسيا في المقابل الامر الاول هو ان
روسيا باتت مصدرا رخيصا للغايه للطاقه الى
الصين وهنا اشارت الشبكه الى عرض بوت
للصفقات السلع طويله الامد باسعار مخفضه
للصين الامر
ظهر في تصريح بوتين يوم امس بامكاننا
امداد الصين بكامل احتياجاتها من الطاقه
الامر الثاني الذي تتطلع له الصين وهو
الحصول على دعم من روسيا اذا دخلت في نزاع
مسلح مع تايوان والتوترات واشنطن بشان شبه
الجزيره
يزداد كل يوم عن سابقه وهناك زياره لرئيسه
تايوان نهايه الشهر للولايات المتحده
الامر الثالث هو تمتع روسيا بميزات كبيره
على مستوى الصناعه العسكريه والتقنيات
النوويه يمكن لبكين ان تستفيد منها